The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
EDDIE SCHOLTZ: So,
I'm Eddie Scholtz
and this is Mike
Fitzgerald and we
worked on a backgammon tutor.
And to start off, let's
see a show of hands.
Who here knows how
to play backgammon?
OK, a few.
So to give you an
idea of how it works,
it involves both skill and luck.
And it's a two player game.
And the object is to
move all your pieces
past your opponent's
pieces and off the board.
So white's trying to
move his pieces this way,
down and across.
And brown's trying to move
his pieces the other way.
And you move by
rolling the dice.
Some important rules
are that you can not
land on a point on
which your opponent has
two or more pieces.
And if your opponent only
has a single piece there,
you can land on it and send
it back to the beginning.
So the goals of this
project when we started off
were, first of all to implement
the rules of backgammon
and get the game going, and
that took a good amount of work.
Next we wanted to create
or find the function that
evaluates or says how
good a given board is.
And then we wanted to be
able to look into the future,
in order to better determine
what move to choose now.
And this is the part of the
program that we parallelized.
And finally our
last goal was to try
to teach the player
how to improve
by suggesting why one move
might be better than another
in English.
So to start with, the two
basic kinds of board evaluation
are just a static
evaluator and a neural net.
And the static evaluator
works by looking
at features of the board
and creating a score based
on that feature, and
then multiplying it
by weight based on how
important that feature is,
and summing them up.
So a program like this was
created by Hans Berliner at CMU
in 1979, and it was
actually the first program
to beat a ruling world champion.
And they said the program got
a little lucky but it did win.
And one of the
important features
was it adjusted the weights
as the game went on,
because certain features
became less important
as the game progressed and other
features became more important.
So the next approach
that people have used
is framing neural nets to
determine how good a board is.
And these have been
really successful.
They work by basically
playing hundreds of thousands,
if not millions of
games against itself.
And so it improves this way.
And after about a
million and half games
it reaches its
maximum performance.
And one such board
evaluator is Pubeval
which was released by
Gerry Tesauro in 1993.
And this is the
evaluation function
that we used for our program.
Looks like we lost
network connection.
This is the evaluation function
that we used for our program.
And he sort of released this
as a benchmark evaluator
so that other people in
the development community
could have something to compare
their evaluators against.
And it plays an
intermediate level if not
a pretty strong level.
So our next goal was
to implement the search
the looks into the
future in order
to help choose
the best move now.
One of the challenges of this
is that the branching factor
is so large because you don't
know what the dice rolls are
going to be in the future.
And like in checkers, the
branching factor is 10.
In chess it's 35 to 40.
But in backgammon, for
a turn it's around 400.
Another challenge that we
faced in the search was
that the Pubeval function
that we used is not zero sum.
So that produced some
challenges that you'll see.
And also there's the question
of whether searching deeper
actually does
produce better play.
And most papers say
that the board evaluator
is more important
than searching deeper.
But they do say that
searching into the future
does improve play, and
especially when you're already
at a pretty high level of play
where everyone's near the same
and playing really well.
A slight increase in performance
could make a big difference.
So here's an illustration
of the search tree
to give you a better
idea of how it works.
So say it's X's turn.
There might be 20 or so
moves that he can commit.
Now these are a series of moves.
So you roll the two
dice, and if they're
doubles you get four moves.
Certain turns you may not be
able to move at all so you
might not have any moves.
So that really varies.
So after those 20
moves the other player,
O is going to roll.
And there's 21 different dice
combinations he can have.
And then for each of those
there's about 20 moves.
And then it's X's roll.
And once again he has
21 dice combinations.
And then X's move.
So this is looking two
moves into the future.
So the idea is to
build this search tree,
and then at this
point we're already
up to 3.5 million boards.
So you have all these leaf nodes
that represent your boards,
and you're going
to evaluate them
with your evaluation function
to determine how good they are.
Since it's not
zero sum, you have
to evaluate it for both player
and both of these values
need to get passed up as you're
going to move back up the tree
to determine the best move.
So you start at
the bottom and you
say that since
it's X's move he's
going to choose the best
possible move given that roll.
And then in order to move
up further and calculate
the value for the
parent node, you
say it's equal to the
probability of the dice
roll for the child node
times the value that's
stored in that child node.
And then you keep doing
this and repeating this.
O picks his best move and sort
of sums the expected value.
And then get back up the top
and X picks his best move.
So now I'm going to
hand it over to Mike
who's going to talk about
the part of the code
that we parallelized.
MIKE FITZGERALD:
There's a question.
AUDIENCE: Quick question.
Can you use alpha beta pruning?
You know about
alpha beta pruning?
EDDIE SCHOLTZ: Yeah.
People have used that and
just like a [INAUDIBLE]
search of narrowing it down.
AUDIENCE: Typically by down
to the square root of n.
So you would have a 20 branch
effect rather than a 400.
It seems like a real payoff if
you could make it work here.
I don't know if there's some
reason on the back end why
it's hard.
EDDIE SCHOLTZ: Well, we actually
didn't get to that point.
We just spent a lot of time just
implementing rules of the game.
MIKE FITZGERALD: All
right, so the first thing
we looked at and said this would
be perfect for parallelizing
is just the brute force
evaluation of those million
boards that you get
down to at the end.
Which if you run through on one
processor just takes a while.
Generally an evaluation of a
board, regardless of its state
takes the same amount of time.
So we just had to split the
number evenly between SPUs.
We had to keep it around
a multiple of four
just to get the DMA calls to
line up nicely with the floats
that we were returning
and things like that.
So if you're evaluating
a million boards which
was our number for our
benchmarks that we did,
each SPU has about
170,000 to handle,
and it clearly can't take
all those over at once.
So each SPU knows where
it's supposed to start
and how many it's
supposed to do.
And it knows how much
it can pull over.
So it does a DMA call to pull
in as much as it can process.
It processes those,
evaluates them, returns them,
and gets to the next bunch.
So that is what we
were able to implement.
There's also a good opportunity
for double buffering there
for pulling them
in as it's actually
evaluating the previous ones.
So that would be actually a
pretty easy step to do next.
But each of those
six are roughly
finished at the same time
and then get back to the PPU
to evaluate, to
run up that tree.
And another opportunity
to make it a bit quicker,
which we didn't
quite get to would
be SIMDizing the
evaluation function
so we could do
four boards at once
with vector engines
instead of just one.
So the performance
that we got when
looking at the number
of SPUs we were using
was actually roughly
in proportional
to the number of
SPUs we were using.
It's actually 18.18
at the top there.
So when using two instead of
one we got just about half.
When using three instead of
one we got just about a third.
If you just look at this speedup
graph it's pretty much one
to one from the
number of SPUs we
were using to the
amount of time it took.
So it was a pretty
efficient algorithm
for splitting those up and
evaluating them and pulling
them back together.
I'll give you a brief demo.
I'll show you
quickly how it looks.
We might have to fudge our
network connection a little bit
here.
So we used just an
[INAUDIBLE] Windows
setup to display our
[INAUDIBLE] we were using.
So I'm just going play a
couple rounds of the display,
let's say against the computer.
So you can see the computer just
took a couple of moves there.
But basically what
we get here is
a print out of a text
representation of the board.
And then it's my turn.
I rolled a six and a two.
It does its own
evaluation and says
this is what the best move combo
would be for me at this point.
In the ideal
tutoring situation we
don't let the user pick what
they thought was the best
and then tell them why
not, but right now,
with the time we had
this is how we did it.
And then it lists all the legal
possible moves you can make.
Let's say I want to
move from 0.6 to 0.4.
It moves my piece up there,
and from 8 to 2 for example.
And the computer makes
its couple of moves.
That's the general idea.
You can run the computer
against itself as many times,
just to test different
evaluation functions
against each other.
You can also do it without
the animation on the GUI
so that it runs a lot quicker.
But that's the general idea.
Just to wrap up,
four more slides.
The way we went
about this basically
was, we just got sequential code
working on just the PPU, got
the rules of the
game worked out,
all the weird
conditionals and things
that can happen in backgammon
and we fixed out our bugs
and our memory leaks
and things like that.
We just shelled out
the parallel code
and got that working on
the PPU, then on one SPU,
and then on six.
So it was a pretty clean
process of doing it.
And we ran into a few walls.
We aren't really
backgammon experts or even
intermediate players, so it
was kind of a new thing for us
to make sure we had
the rules right,
and we weren't doing stupid
things here and there.
But also managing the
search tree was a big deal.
And looking at what
the program has
to do in running
the game, that's
the next thing we want to tackle
as far as paralyzing goes.
It takes a while, and
it's pretty tough.
We ran into some memory
management issues
with how we were
representing our boards.
We were able to
pack them down into,
I think 24 byte structure,
20 byte structure
to be able to pass more
to the SPUs at one time.
PROFESSOR: [INAUDIBLE]
What's the general idea
for [INAUDIBLE]?
MIKE FITZGERALD:
I'm sorry, I missed
the beginning of your
question because it
wasn't on speakerphone.
PROFESSOR: [INAUDIBLE].
EDDIE SCHOLTZ: Are you talking
about moving into the future?
Are you talking about
looking into the future?
Yeah.
So we built the code
for creating that tree
and evaluating the leaf nodes.
We didn't quite have
time to finish up--
PROFESSOR: [INAUDIBLE]
I can't hear you
through this [INAUDIBLE].
EDDIE SCHOLTZ: OK.
We created the code for
constructing the tree
and evaluating the leaf nodes.
We haven't quite has
time to finish up
moving back up the tree.
So at this point we're
now looking ahead more
than just the moves for
now, for like one move.
PROFESSOR: OK.
OK.
EDDIE SCHOLTZ: But we
got the parallel code
working for actually
evaluating the boards.
It shouldn't be too hard to--
MIKE FITZGERALD: Just
extend that tree.
EDDIE SCHOLTZ: To
move back up the tree
and see what the
best move is now.
EDDIE SCHOLTZ: Yeah, so
that's basically as far
as the road blocks we hit were.
EDDIE SCHOLTZ: Any
other questions?
Yeah, just some future ideas.
One of the big ones is for
training, the evaluation
functions using neural nets.
That takes a lot of time to
play hundreds of thousands,
millions of games.
So one of the ideas
is to parallelize
that to help speed that up.
And I think we're about out
of time, so that concludes it.
Are there any questions?
AUDIENCE: I'm just
curious, you said
looking far into the
future doesn't necessarily
help as much as the
evaluation function.
Does that mean
that AI backgammon
is-- I mean how computationally
intensive is a good player?
I mean, is it a
computationally problem?
Would you benefit
from the parallelism
in a practical setting?
MIKE FITZGERALD:
Well, just looking
at how long it takes to go
through those million boards,
if you're playing a
computer you don't
want to wait 18 seconds for them
to make their move as opposed
to--
AUDIENCE: Oh, so that's
time scale of the absolute?
If you just ran on a
uni-processor for 20 seconds
kind of a thing?
MIKE FITZGERALD: Yeah, once
you're doing a million boards.
And also, if you're on
the level of competing
against really good competitors,
just having a deep search tree
to get that much more
of an edge would make
a difference in that situation.
Anyone else?
No?
EDDIE SCHOLTZ: Great.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]